[Music]
I've spent thousands of hours of my life
playing video games from the days of my
Amiga 600 all the way to the current
generation of consoles but I've also
spent thousands of hours playing
football on concrete playgrounds across
fields in Ireland on Hackney Marshes and
even here in Oakland football soccer or
whatever you call it there's a reason
it's so popular first of all and it's
wonderfully simple a ball of two goals
some legs and a bunch of physics to the
uninitiated it might seem like a bunch
of people just running around after a
ball but look a while longer and you
realize why it's called the beautiful
game somewhere between the certainty of
where you want to place the shot and the
reality of where it lands magic is made
it's a feeling that gamers are all too
familiar with and while modern video
games are often big complex things with
lots of buttons and moving parts there's
a lot to be said for beautiful
simplicity this week on the point we
talk about head sticking Rockets on the
cars made one of the most enjoyable
football games of recent memory and how
there's nothing simple about making a
beautifully simple game
[Music]
rocket League was released by
Californian developer psionics on
PlayStation 4 and PC
earlier this month it's a game when you
play soccer while driving a car so quite
had a team managed to not call it stock
car as anyone's guys games take place in
an enclosed dome with nets on either
side and though a standard game is 3v3
you can play with as few as one per team
or as many as four along with being
nimble and fast accelerators the cars
are also able to pull off a variety of
jumps and spins it's pretty simple press
the button to jump and press another
button plus a direction to spin your car
just like in footy your body is a tool
to move the ball into the goal the
entire ball needs to cross the line
there are no weapons but you can pick up
boosts to help you get a speed advantage
you play online with strangers friends
or against box games are 5 minutes long
and it's an absolute blast simple idea
right soccer with cars got it seems like
video games should have made this years
ago but even the simplest of idea had to
start somewhere and would you believe it
this story starts with one of my
favorite online games of all time and
man you know I love any excuse to talk
about Unreal Tournament
don't get me problem Oh Unreal
Tournament has always been a shooter
which encouraged experimentation the
original game launched with half a dozen
game modes spread across a wild variety
of map styles and sizes it was mod
friendly - and even launched with a
mutator system which applied bizarre
modifiers to each level stuff like
instigate low gravity or the more you
kill people the fatter you get perhaps
it wasn't what we call balance today but
it was fun as hell and this was a staple
of the series thread its lifespan
bedroom programmers buoyed by this sense
of anything-goes took to making their
own bizarre maps and mods Unreal
Tournament 2003 continued this trend
with several new game modes
perhaps strangest the most memorable of
which being bombing run a form of
American football where players scored
goals by shooting field goals and
running in touchdowns with a big metal
fall however that version of UT also had
the groundwork for some vehicles that
never quite made it into the game typing
summoned vehicles bulldog into the dev
console would spawn a jeep with rockets
but it wasn't actually usable in the
game that was until a bedroom programmer
named Dave Page would decided to wrap a
motor and creating a new type of vehicle
combat game it's called the eye of epic
games within hired age wood to develop a
brand new mode for their upcoming game
maybe you've heard of it it's Unreal
Tournament 2004 as onslaught mode for me
onslaught was the reason to play ut2004
are much like football I devoted
hundreds of hours to capturing points
and murdering people with its cool new
vehicles it was an absolute blast but it
had a lot of moving parts so games would
often be immediate blow overs are
never-ending stalemates as the sheer
number of possible tactical options made
it hard for large teams to work in
unison but there was something in there
something amidst all the vehicles and
waypoints and guns an idea an idea worth
exploring for David his time working at
epic inspired him to start his own
studio psionics according to this
wonderful interview Ron Gamasutra the
team used their experience with the
unveiling
to form a business helping other Studios
with their unreal games this work helped
them from their own projects while
working on these games they kept toying
with their unreal car project all the
while the world of UT kept growing
deathball and Unreal Tournament 2004
soccer mod had gained popularity
eventually somebody on the team put two
and two together creating a tech demo
her soccer based car game and the studio
fell in love with it
they self-published this game on
PlayStation Network for the ps3 in 2008
and those supersonic acrobatic
rocket-powered bottle cars never quite
managed to reach mainstream success they
were one step closer to that beautifully
simple game watch footage of this game
alongside rocket league in the two are
remarkably similar but 7 years of
tweaking 11 to refine this idea they
fine-tune the feel of the car may the
arena's simpler change the location of
boost pads and gave it a sneaker style
so by the time the game launched for
free on PlayStation Plus earlier this
month it was so immediately playable so
wonderfully satisfying and fun that the
online servers the team setup couldn't
deal with the load and promptly crashed
so here's the thing rocket league is
absolutely brilliant you've probably
gathered that from the reviews the tweet
streams and from all your mates telling
you about it but it's something else for
somebody like me who's kicked around the
leather ball for untold hours who's
played FIFA and pro-am for years and
years and years rocket league is
something very special it's the closest
thing to real football that a football
game has ever gotten
I love footie games from sensible soccer
all the way through Pro Evan the
Renaissance of FIFA but all those games
have one thing in common you control an
entire team you play as a unit 10 people
working as one mind to get the ball into
the opposing team's net but that's not
actually how football works you don't
play as a team you play on a tee and
with that comes an entirely different
style of play it forces you to pick a
role a striker who's up there to score a
winger who crosses the ball in from the
sides or a goalkeeper protecting the net
and much more powerfully by playing on a
team with others it forces your ego to
the surface it makes you want to impress
others which
Guil and crucially not to let the team
down and it's in that way that rocket
League is more like a real kick a bet
with your friends than any football game
before us that cold sweat when you're
the last man back with less than a
minute to go on a clock rocket league
has that the humiliation of missing an
open goal in front of you teammates
because you just slightly misjudged the
angle of your approach rocket league has
- and that feeling we have a spot on the
goal that you're sure you can hit and
you kick the ball and it hits it rocket
league has that too and that's really
special because in traditional soccer
games crucial elements are interacting
with the ball momentum power accuracy
all of these are handled by statistics
and the button you press in rocket
League your car is your leg your chest
your forehead you take the ball down you
diving header in crosses and you speed
up to strike from outside the box
clearing the ball off the line with a
bicycle kick doing keepy uppies with
your teammates hammering the ball off a
concrete wall for a rebound going up for
the cross playing last man back
dribbling around the last defender while
games like fifa concentrate on the
spectacle of football the teams the
players the competitions the diving the
corruption rocket League rests are more
familiar going passing the ball to your
mace scoring that absolute streamer and
having just one more game before the Sun
sets and while it may seem like a
perfectly simple game in concept it took
devoted developers over a decade of
tinkering Timmy get feels so simple
psionics have accidentally on purpose
created the most football like football
game ever made a game of one touch
endure three aside football just with
cars and rockets and a selection of
dashing hats and how fitting it is that
this game comes out during the summer
the time of year when people spend more
time outside and fewer games are
released so maybe once the sun's gone
down perhaps she could sit down so
the games of rocket me fall in love with
rocket Li because just like real
football it really is a beautiful game
[Music]